[Music]
the tibetan
high plateau lies about four thousand
five hundred meters above sea level
with only sixty percent of the oxygen
found below
while visitors and recent settlers
struggle with altitude sickness
native tibetans sprint up mountains
this ability comes not from training or
practice
but from changes to a few genes that
allow their bodies to make the most of
limited oxygen
these differences are apparent from
birth tibetan babies have
on average higher birth weights higher
oxygen saturation
and are much likelier to survive than
other babies born in this environment
these genetic changes are estimated to
have evolved over the last three
thousand years or so
and are ongoing that may sound like a
long time
but would be the fastest an adaptation
has ever evolved
in a human population it's clear that
human evolution
isn't over so what are other recent
changes
and will our technological and
scientific innovations
impact our evolution in the past few
thousand years
many populations have evolved genetic
adaptations to their local environments
people in siberia and the high arctic
are uniquely adapted to survive extreme
cold they're slower to develop frostbite
and can continue to use their hands in
sub-zero temperatures much longer than
most people
they've undergone selection for a higher
metabolic rate
that increases heat production
further south the bajao people of
southeast asia
can dive 70 meters and stay underwater
for almost
15 minutes over thousands of years
living as nomadic hunters at sea
they have genetically hardwired
unusually large spleens
that act as oxygen stores enabling them
to stay underwater for longer
an adaptation similar to that of deep
diving
seals though it may seem pedestrian by
comparison
the ability to drink milk is another
such adaptation
all mammals can drink their mother's
milk as babies
after weaning they switch off the gene
that allows them to digest
milk but communities in sub-saharan
africa
the middle east and northwest europe
that used cows for milk
have seen a rapid increase in dna
variants that prevent the gene from
switching off
over the last seven to eight thousand
years
at least in europe milk drinking may
have given people a source of calcium
to aid in vitamin d production as they
moved north
and sunlight the usual source of vitamin
d
decreased though not always in obvious
ways
all of these changes improve people's
chance of surviving to reproductive
age that's what drives natural selection
the force behind
all these evolutionary changes modern
medicine
removes many of these selective
pressures by keeping us alive when our
genes
sometimes combined with infectious
diseases would have killed us
antibiotics vaccines clean water and
good sanitation
all make differences between our genes
less important
similarly our ability to cure childhood
cancers
surgically extract inflamed appendixes
and deliver babies whose mothers have
life-threatening pregnancy-specific
conditions all tend to stop selection
by allowing more people to survive to a
reproductive age
but even if every person on earth has
access to modern medicine
it won't spell the end of human
evolution that's because there are other
aspects of evolution besides
natural selection modern medicine makes
genetic variation that would have been
subject to natural selection
subject to what's called genetic drift
instead with genetic drift genetic
differences vary
randomly within a population on a
genetic level
modern medicine might actually increase
variety
because harmful mutations don't kill
people and thus aren't eliminated
this variation doesn't necessarily
translate to observable or phenotypic
differences among people however
researchers have also been investigating
whether genetic adaptations to a
specific environment
could appear very quickly through
epigenetic modification
changes not to genes themselves but to
whether and when
certain genes are expressed these
changes can happen during a lifetime
and may even be passed to offspring but
so far researchers are conflicted over
whether epigenetic modifications can
really persist
over many generations and lead to
lasting changes
in populations there may
also be other contributors to human
evolution modern medicine
and technology are very new even
compared to the quickest most recent
changes by natural selection
so only time can tell how our present
will
shape our future
earth is 4.5 billion years old
how did humans come to define it in such
a tiny fraction of that time
is what makes us brilliant the same
thing that makes us deadly
explore our place in the universe with
sapiens
download a free audiobook version from
audible.com
ted-ed and consider what's next
for our kind